propos justement de faire le point sur
ce taux d'abstention de ce scrutin donc
de dimanche qu'elle a été la
participation est des idées noires vous
en avez déjà un peu parlé c'est bien 400
go journalistes portés sont 18 vous êtes
là avec nous pour faire le point bonsoir
bonsoir donc est-ce que déjà vous pouvez
nous éclairer est ce qu'ils se sont
mobilisés les yvelinois pour ce premier
tour eh bien on va commencer par un
chiffre significatif
ce chiffre c'est
48,13 % c'est le taux d'abstention et
des élections législatives pour ce
premier tour en légère hausse par
rapport à 2010 est il été de 47,80 de
42% par rapport au chiffre national les
yvelinois sont de meilleurs élèves le
département des yvelines est
généralement au dessus de la moyenne
nationale puisqu'il atteint un taux
record pour un premier tour depuis 1958
avec
52,49 % alors hier soir on a interrogé
des candidats qui ont réagi au score de
leurs diverses circonscriptions les
élections législatives par principe des
là il ya peu de gens qui vont voter et
nous c'est vrai qu'on a essayé de jouer
sur une campagne vraiment pour les
jeunes notamment de les investir et
c'est vrai que malheureusement les
jeunes se sont beaucoup abstenus notre
circonscription a voté un petit peu plus
que la moyenne nationale donc ça c'est
bien on va essayer d'encourager les gens
quand même à se déplacer à voter encore
la semaine prochaine parce que c'est ce
que je crains le plus pour la semaine
prochaine parce que les gens qui n'ont
plus leurs candidats au deuxième tour
des fois staps tiennent plutôt que de
voter j'ai lu locale vous savez quand on
essaye de se donner on essaye de 2,2
faire beaucoup pour nos territoires on a
cette passion des territoires est
effectivement de voir qu'il ya autant
d'abstention c'est aussi une marque de
désintérêt des français de la politique
et je trouve ça bien dommage
alors on le voit est lésé lieu ne
comprennent pas pourquoi les électeurs
ne votent plus le taux d'abstention une
cesse d'augmenter et même ces élections
législatives 2022 n'ont pas réussi à
faire rêver certains les élus eux disent
que la campagne n'a pas décollé rafa est
le matin duvignau pourquoi les élections
législatives depuis quelques années ne
passionne plus
alors ce n'était pas simple ce ne sont
pas simplement les ex-miliciens cliffs
et dominèrent général les élections ne
passionne plus ou plusieurs raisons la
première raison c'est que l'homme
politique ne correspond pas ou ne
correspond plus aux aspirations des
citoyens ça c'est un premier lot un
deuxième élément c'est qu'il ya seront
construits réels ou imaginés ou
fantasmée du fait que le personnel
politique est plus ou moins corrompus
cet élitisme bref il ya une défiance
envers le personnel politique il ya une
crise bien s'y pique entre la population
les citoyens d'un côté et le père trail
politique de l'autre et donc finalement
rien ne se retrouvent plus alors que
c'est essentiel ne se retrouvent plus
dans le personnel politique ensuite une
sorte de wii les gens sont désabusés
finalement il considère que le personnes
politiques quels qu'ils soient ne
répondra pas leurs aspirations ne
répondra pas à leurs attentes
effectivement il ya aussi le fait depuis
le quinquennat que les élections
législatives viennent juste après les
présidentielles et que tout s'est joué
lors de l'élection présentielle élection
majeure en france et que au final on
sert à rien la veulent dit très
simplement ça ne sert à rien d'aller
voter aux législatives puisque un
président élu avec une île aura manif
mécaniquement une majorité donc ça peut
expliquer aussi ce désintérêt
l'abstention touche aussi davantage les
jeunes et les catégories populaires
c'est l'on prend par circonscription
dans la huitième l'abstention atteint 58
29 75% et si on prend la ville de
mantes-la-jolie plus de 63% des
électeurs ne se sont pas déplacés alors
direction la 9e circonscription avec un
taux d'abstention de 52
94% parmi les communes de ce territoire
ou dans guerville bonnières sur seine ou
encore les mureaux les mureaux avec un
taux record aussi environ 70% de taux
d'abstention alors deux autres
circonscriptions dépasse la barre des
50% de taux d'abstention la septième et
la 11e et on va finir quand même sur des
villes qui se sont mobilisés maisons
laffitte le chesnay rocancourt le mesnil
saint denis le vésinet est le chef le
chef lieu du département versailles
merci beaucoup c'est bien get on go pour
ces informations journalistes pour tv 78